how old was freddie prince when he died
i don't even think it was freddie
princess junior related
yes that's his son yeah that's his son
how old is he
22. he was sheets and a half 22.
holy [ __ ] you know what i still remember
oh my [ __ ]
want me to tell you why i remember that
night specifically because i had
on the way home it was so [ __ ] cold
that i had to cut through the cemetery
and when i was walking to the cemetery i
had to take a [ __ ]
oh no and i went in front of a [ __ ]
casket the guy had been buried
in like 1920 so i go [ __ ] it he's got no
family left right
it was freezing joe rogan freezing
i pull my pants down to my knees i squat
i take a [ __ ] and i start pissing and
all of a sudden i go to get up and i
pissed in my own pants my
pants were frozen i had to walk home
like the tin man
because the piss went right into the
[ __ ] pants and i walked in and my
mother was there
but i walked in with pee on me and she's
like what are we doing here
what do i gotta do like what i gotta do
i gotta kill another chicken
what are we doing here is the funny [ __ ]
you could say every time i came home
with an idea my mother turned to
santoria like that's it
i gotta call you godmother i can't
handle this no more
when i started dressing up like bruce
lee and i had incense in my room
and a bowl of rice
oh i had the outfit the white shirt that
you folded
i bowed i [ __ ] learned how to use
chopsticks my mother would go
that's it you got to go to your
godmother's house you got a problem
something's wrong with you
you're not chinese stupid you're not
chinese